27 juin
2023 la mort à Nanterre du jeune Naël
lors d'un contrôle de police provoque
dans toute la France un
embrasement d'une ampleur
inédite pendant 6 nuits consécutives des
épisodes de violence urbain se succèdent
dans les grandes métropoles mais aussi
dans des villes qui n'avaient jamais
affronté de Tell situation ils sont
policiers
élu mare de famille habitant des
quartiers magistrats ils vivent à vaau
envelin en banlieu de Lyon et à
montargie dans le
Loiret 3 mois après les émeutes dans ces
deux villes de France nous avons
rencontré celles et ceux qui étaient
hier en première ligne et qui dessinent
aujourd'hui la vie d'après
[Musique]
elle est surnommée avec un peu d'emphase
la Venise du gaâtinet montargie
sous-préfecture du Loiret a la
réputation d'une cité tranquille à 1h
dem de Paris une ville étape appréciée
pour son centre historique et ses
[Musique]
Canau mais depuis quelques semaines une
PL béante défigure la carte
postale derrière ces barrières au mois
de juin encore se trouvait la Grande
Pharmacie du Centre une chocolaterie et
une cordonnerie
mais au cours d'une nuit d'émeutes ces
commerces sont tous partis en fumé
incendiés
volontairement plus
rien est tout est anéanti tout est
détruit 12 ans
de de
travail voilà plus rien Patrick V était
le patron de la chocolaterie jamais il
n'aurait imaginé de telles scènes
possibles dans la viille
é la façade carrément qui s'est
écroulé cru en temps de guerre c'était
impressionnant on croit pas nos yeux une
petite ville tranquille
calme est pas dans les grosses
villesoss vill comme Marseille Bordeaux
et qui nous tombe sur la
tête
juste send dit le centre commerçant de
la petite ville tranquille est m à sac
par près de 250 hémetiers cagoulé du
jamais vu à montargie et pour les
habitants un traumatisme c'est une
Dinger qui se durable je n'ai jamais vu
une une émeute comme ça nulle part de ma
vie pourtant j'ai j'ai connu mes
mais voir
ça c'est c'est de la folie hein céit de
la folie il m'a fallu une semaine pour
retrouver le calme et un peu
de pu cette rue maintenant elle est
triste vous regardez à droite à gauche
tout est fermé c'est
calré
c'est 3 mois plus tard la rue doré
poumon commerçant de montarg reste
couverte de
cicatrice les sorties shopping du samedi
n'y ont plus la même saveur
les impacts sur les vitrines les
palissades en bois rappellent encore en
permanence la violence de cette nuitl
Patrick ver ne sait pas s'il rouvrira un
jour sa boutique en attendant il est
soutenu moralement par les commerçants
voisins les émeutes sont encore dans les
têtes c'est ça pour l'instant c'est pas
possible de tourner la page après une
catastrophe comme ça après 3 mois non
c'est impossible on est dans tous les
jours
c'est puis tout me le rappelle quoi tout
le temps je SCE que tous les papiers les
fournisseurs les machins je suis dedans
tous les jours donc moi avant je ne
fermer pas mes rideaux métalliques la
porte est suffisamment sécurisée il y a
le système d'alarme enfin voilà on se
dit il n'arrivera rien et et pourtant
maintenant tous les soirs j'ai pris
voilà le pli et l'habitude de fermer mes
rideaux métalliques je me dis parce que
peut-être peut-être on sait pas ça peut
recommencer parce que peut-être encore
un policier va faire quelque chose
malheureusement dentellement que ça va
encore partir un petit peu en live ça va
encore dégénérer sou suite merci vous
tiens en courou avec plaisir c'est
gentil merci merci à
bientôt 80 commerces ont été attaqués à
montargie Sébastien drapala est le chef
de la police
municipale il était positionné dans la
rue doré le soir des émeutes cette
boutique làah c'est une boutique
téléphonique avait été également Pée bon
de tout son contenu que éta de la
téléphonie et depuis ça paraî ouvert
quoi c'est vrai que le magasin est resté
en standby comme ça donc c'était rapide
avec de la mobilité des choses rapides
des téléphones à mettre dans les poches
après ils ont essayé des bijouteries les
bijouteries ont des vites quand même qui
sont beaucoup plus sécurisé donc ils ont
pas réussi à pénétrer à l'intérieur des
bijouterie quoi face aux hémetiers les
policiers ont tenté vaille que vaille de
défendre la rue commerçante mais sans
parvenir à éviter le sacage nous on
était une quinzaine contre 100 à 150
individus quoi donc du coup c'est vrai
que dès qu'on essayait de progresser
pour repousser les individus
malheureusement pour notre sécurité on
devait
reculer on Essé trop de tirs de mortier
de mobilier urbain donc on a chaque fois
reculé et on a essayé la police
nationale a utiliser plusieurs fois des
grenades lacrymogènes les lanceurs de
Bales de défense mais malheureusement on
n'a pas pu les repousser étant donné le
nombre important
d'individus tous les véhicules qui
étaient encore stationnés il est
retourné pour les incendiés pour faire
un peu des barrages des poubelles donc
tout ce qui est resté les panneaux
publicitaires tout a été incendié ou
jeté vers les forces de l'ordre quoi des
affrontements et avec autant de
personnes structuré et avec une haine de
telle ampleur on n' jamais connu ça moi
j'ai jamais connu ça sur montarg non
effectivement pendant que les policiers
faisaient front à quelques rues de là le
maire lui passait la nuit au centre de
vidéosurveillance de la ville Monsieur
le Maire bonjour Bien et vous ouais mot
la presse j'étais là avec Monsieur le
sous-préfet de montargie
mes adjoints et mon chef de cabinet puis
on a assisté au désastre au pillage de
la
ville vous êtes comme ça vous êtes collé
devant les écrans voyz des images c'est
quasiment irréel on se rend pas compte
de ce qui se passe on se rend compte
mais le temps vous absorbiez ce ce choc
il faut un certain temps
heatt on peut pas être prêt face à un
tsunami personne n'est prêt face à ça un
tsunami ou un BL vous faites comme vous
voulez mais c'est quand même une guerre
éclaire c'est un truc c'est une vague
qui est passée en 3 He on peut pas
supposer que ça puisse exister
maintenant on le sait hein mais c'est
quelque chose de de terrible c'est
soudain c'est pas attendu on sait qu'il
y a des difficultés les difficultés
économiques on les connaît mais c'était
à mon avis c'est pas lié à tout ça c'est
lié à à une vague de un défouloir je
vous ai dit c'est un défouloir de d'une
jeunesse qui qui s'est
lâché mais emmené par des leaders qui
sont des gens négatifs hein
effectivement on voit que c'est quand
même structuré et organisé donc je pense
qu'il y a eu des rassemblements qui sont
fait via les réseaux sociaux parce que
ils sont arrivés tous en nombre à 150 à
200 personnes en même temps au même
endroit en centreville donc on voit
qu'il y a eu une organisation et ça a
été structuré en amont bien en amont oui
effectivement
oui les images de vidéosurveillance ont
été transmises au parquet certains
hémetiers interpellés en flagrant des
lit ont été jugés en comparution
immédiate juste après les faits ces
audiences ont permis de mieux cerner
leur profil leur organisation et leur
motivation Jean-Cédric ga est le
procureur de montargie il a vu les
prévenus se succéder à la
barre les forces de l'ordre ont
interpellé et nous avons pris des
décisions pour 18 individus 18 hmetiers
il y a parmi ces 18 personnes 10 mineurs
et majeurs dans l'immense majorité de
ces ind id il n'avait pas d'antécédent
judiciire presque la quasi totalité
était simplement connue parfois des
services de police qui les côtoi dans
les quartiers de montargier de son
agglomération à aucun moment il n a eu
d'évocation de Nael m à l'origine de ses
émeutes à aucun moment il n'y a eu par
exemple de T de tag revendicatif à aucun
moment aucune revendication de nature
politique on pourrait dire n'a été faite
il a été é évoqué bien une présence
opportuniste ou un effet de
groupe peut-être du
suivisme pas de message évident derrière
ces actes qui disent tout de même
quelque chose sur
montargie ce qui m'est apparu de de
nouveau c'est la
révélation peut-être du fossé qui
s'élargissait entre et bien une partie
de notre jeunesse qui vit dans les
quartiers difficile et vous observerez
que le fait pour ces quartiers d' p
pphérique à la ville de venir dans le
centre-ville dans la principale rue
commerçante c'était un acte symbolique
me semble-t-il de l'préension que j'en
ai de de vengeance pour dire au
centre-ville entre guillemets riches et
bien qu'il avait des difficultés
sociales des quartiers
périphérique la chaussée est l'un des
quartiers périphériques de
montargie en bas des tours nous
rencontrons des maires de famille isolés
pris en charge par une association alors
que les habitants du centreeville reste
sidéré leur ressenti à elle n'est pas le
même moi perso ça m'a pas surpris tous
les soirs on entend des tirs de mortier
lundi mardi mercredi des cross t les
toutes les nuits même à 9h le matin on a
des voitures brûlé régulèr donc ma
voiture ma voiture moi je me suis fait
voler ma voiture et brûler dans les
champs plus loin je pense aussi que les
jeunes quand ils voient leurs parents
aussi galérer alors qu'il y en a qui ont
tout ça peut
faire ça peut faire ça peut énerver ça
peut
voilà donc je P ça pe aller péter deux
trois vitrines la nuit pour prendre et
revendre et c'est ça qui s passeou quand
vous voyez que le copain à l'école il a
eu un scooter et puis que vous vous
arrivez même pas à avoir un vélo pour
venir à l'école à un moment je j'excuse
pas mais je dis qu' un moment quand on
est enfant même à dos on se dit c'est
pas juste j'ai un enfant de 14 ans qui
est très difficile et j'ai eu peur
je les ai surveillé je les ai maintenus
à la maison il faut pas lâcher la garde
quoi il faut vraiment être très vigilant
par rapport à il y a quand même une
violence qui
augmente 60 % des mineurs interpellés
lors des émeutes sont issus de famille
monoparentales dans ces quartier
difficile parfois pour les M seuls de
maintenir leurs enfants à l'écart des
violences ils sont curieux donc des fois
le danger ça leur fait pas peur ils sont
pas conscients ils vont peut-être le
faire avec s'ils sont en groupe c'est ça
en fait on a peur des fois quand ils
sont en bande qu'il se ils s'entraînent
à faire des choses je pense pas que nous
parents on est la main mise sur tout
hein et là non on pe pas moi je dis tout
ce qui est bien à ma fille mais je suis
pas à l'abri que un jour elle décide de
faire tout l'inverse parce que elle aura
envie d' d'essayer ou je sais pas c'est
difficile aux maman d'être au travail le
matin de surveiller les enfants de
rentrer tard le soir les enfants se sont
pas là d'aller les rechercher donc je
pense que la responsabilité
familiale certes ça peut exister mais
c'est pas une généralité
entre les mises en garde des parents la
tentation d'aller voir ce qui se passe
et les vidéos circulant sur leurs écrans
les adolescents des quartiers de
montargie ont été bouleversés par la
spirale des
événements je le voyais sur les
réseaux sur snapchat sur Instagram
partout et c'est même passé sur BFM TV
dans certaines villes c'était en mode
qui cassera le plus h exactement et
c'était même plus par rapport à la mort
de et carrément j'ai sortais super avec
ma mère et en fait j'ai entendais des
gens ils disaient ouais rassembler les
mortiers tout ça et tout parce qu'ils
allaient faire ça le soir même je les
entendais parler de ça en gros ils
allaient faire et quand par hasard après
on a vu sur les réseaux je va pas
balancer où parce qu'aès on nous voit
comme ça on Fa ça on fait ça on fait ça
alors qu'on est pas tous comme oui on
est pas tous comme ça on est pas tous
comme ça je pense que ça donne du coup
une mauvaise image de la ville et des
jeunes de la ville aussi ça CR des
stéréotypes exactement exactement c'est
quoi ce stéréotype bah les les jeunes
des quartiers ils sont tous comme ça à
cause de de certaines personnes ils
disent que il faut une généralité avec
tous les jeunes des quartiers qui sont
comme
ça encore sonné la ville tente pas à pas
de retrouver sa vie
[Musique]
d'avant aujourd'hui le maire rend visite
au gérant d'un bar tabac qui vient de
recevoir une bonne
nouvelle bonjour bonjour Monsieur le
Maire ça va ça va et vous ça y est ça y
est impeccable on a eu
le on a eu l'arrêté hier soir de
l'expert mais il y a aucun problème vous
pouvez réouvrir d'accord ok merci donc
vous aurez la communication lundi mais
là est arrivé à 9h hier soir et on a on
a l'expert judiciaire à validé merci
beaucoup à vous en tout cas donc ça y
est c'est repris ouais c'est vous av la
livraison de tabac c'est arrivé arrivé
mercredi matin ah bà pour l'instant
c'est une belle journée he franchement
ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisir et pour vous de voir un commerce
qui ritouvre ah bah c'est c'est une
victoire hein je suis content pour lui
surtout parce que fait 3 mois qu'il tire
la langue hein il a plus de revenu il a
plus rienin votre assureur c'est le
quotidien du maire reste accaparé par
les suites de la nuit des
meutes ah ben je passe 5 à 6 heures par
jour les gens se rendent pas compte du
travail que ça donne au maire à la
mairie les son sousension en permanent
c'est les assurances les experts les
avocats les les assurés aussi les les
gens de la ville faire en sorte que les
les vitrines soient remises en service
normalement travaillez bien et rempz la
caisse c'est ce qu'il
faut aider les commerces à rouvrir c'est
la priorité de Benoît Dijon mais il a
une autre
obsession mettre du bleu dans la ville
voilà de l'autorité du bleu des
policiers il nous manque une trentaine
d'effec
lace nationale il faut effec so retrou
et çasieur n coupera pas même s nous
annonce 10 policiers qui arriv au MO de
novembre il y en a 10 qui s'en vont
actuellement donc ça pour nous
l'opération elle est blanche
actuellement des moyens de police en
réponse à une réalité nouvelle les
flambé de violence peuvent désormais
frapper tout le territoire français
comme montarg de très nombreuses villes
petites et moyennes ont été touché par
les
émeutes de façon plus attendue les zones
périphériques des grandes métropoles se
sont aussi
[Musique]
enflammées dans l'agglomération
lyonnaise il est une ville dont l'image
est depuis longtemps associée aux
affrontements urbains Vau envelin tout
le contraire de montargie ici cette
réalité est encrée depuis plusieurs
générations c'est à vaau envelin que la
France a connu sa première grande série
d'émeutes en
la nuit dernière en effet des dizaines
de jeunes se sont affrontés très
violemment avec des policiers tout a
démarré après la mort d'un jeune motard
le pilote d'une Honda à 1000 cm CUB perd
le contrôle de sa moto en sens inverse
arrive une voiture de police le passager
de la moto sans casque Thomas Claudio 21
ans est décédé durant son transfert à
l'hôpital
21h30 hier soir les jeunes se
rassemblent rodéo jette pierre ils
brûlent leur première voiture ces
combats se poursuivent une odeur de gaz
lacrymogène plane sur la ville elle
entame sa 3è nuit chaude franchement
j'ai peur j'ai des enfants je voudrais
pas que ça recommence j'ai jamais vu ça
de ma vie Jafar grangech est un militant
associatif très impliqué dans le
quartier sensible du M du taureau c'est
là qu'avaient débuté les émeutes de
1990 moi j'avais 5 ans donc j'ai pas
trop de souvenirs les seuls souvenirs
que je garde de ces ces événements là en
en 90 c'est un soir on rentrait avec mon
père et en rentrant je vois le la place
du M du taureau qui est un peu plus haut
qui est complètement barricadé ou rempli
de car de
CRS 33 ans plus tard Vau envelin s'est à
nouveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
embrasé ici presque pas de pillage comme
à montargie mais des scènes de violence
proche de la Guera urbaine avec la
police
la question des relations avec les
forces de l'ordre semble ici beaucoup
plus
prignante comment ça va Jafar Grinch et
les membres de son association
dialoguent au quotidien avec les jeunes
du ma du
taureau avec eux ils essaient de
comprendre les mécanismes à l'origine
des tensions avec la
police si on vous pose la question
aujourd'hui vous avez vécu comment le là
les derniers événements tu trouves
normal que ça a pété àau ouais c'est
normal ouais je trouve ça normal ouais
je trouve ça normal parce que c'est
c'est inadmissible ce qui s'est passé à
Paris c'est c'est c'est c'est quelque
chose d'or du commun le le fait que na
fait que le policier tire sur à
boutortant pu arriver à tout le monde
parce que je me suis dit ça il a 17 ans
ça aurait pu être nous ça aurait pu être
moi lui lui c'est ça aurait pu être
n'importe qui qui qui est ici moi
j'étais pour les émeutes parce que entre
la police qui ici qui nous fait des
bavures à chaque fois qu'il nous voit
qui nous qui nous insulte qui se moque
de nous entre entre ça et entre la mort
de de Naël bah moi j'ai trouvé que il
méritait on en a souvent parlé de ça
quand il dit pour c'est
entre parenthèses c'est compréhensible
que ça peut être mérité que certaines
personnes pensent que c'est que c'est
mérité que ce révolte parce que comme
comme on a dit tout à l'heure on pense
tous pareil du fait que que du moment où
ils ont le même uniforme et ils font la
même ils font le ils ont les mêmes
services les mêmes pratiques ils sont
tous dans le même lot en vrai peut-être
que lui aussi il te voit comme étant
tous dans le même sac non bah pourquoi
j'ai pas d'uniforme moi tu viens de la
bang peut-être que il identif tous les
jeunes deu commetant des jeunes qui vont
être un peu compliqués la relation avec
avec l'institution elle est pas stable
donc du coup faut la recréer faut
recréer qu vous dites l'institution ça
peut être l'institution
fa
[Musique]
truc comp
C côé force de l'ordre les émeutes de Jo
on aussi laissé des traces et accentu un
malaise
nous sommes avec la compagnie
départementale d'intervention de la
police nationale ce sont ces hommes qui
ont directement affronter les émetiers
dans l'agglomération
lyonnaise pour nous en parler il nous
emmène sur le plateau des Minguettes
commune de
vénicieux c'est une zone un petit peu
sensible forcément où pour travailler
certaines précautions à
prendre donc d'e manière générale quand
on arrive ce soirl le tram le tram est
bloqué juste en face de nous par les
émetiers et on est accueilli avec un
ensemble de jet
projecties on s'est aperçu queils
étaient de plus en plus nombreux qui
cherchaient à créer une espèce de front
entre guillemets face à nous et il
tentai de nous contourner donc ça a été
pendant presque 1h3 quasiment
2h beaucoup de moyens pyrotechniques
quasiment pas nonstop mais pas loin
énormément énormément de de feu
d'artifice de de
mortiers est-ce que vous ressentez de la
haine à votre rencontre chez les émotiv
bien sûr oui clairement clairement le le
l'objectif est de casser du flic pour
certains oui on le sait sur ce genre
d'événement enfin on entend énormément
d'insultes d'insultte de menace de mort
et autres après voilà le dialogue est
quand même assez restreint une fois que
la situation est dégradée à ce point-là
il y a pas a quand même assez peu de de
dialogue
un constat s'impose c'est aujourd'hui
l'impasse entre les policiers et
certains habitants des
quartiers il y a le terrain qui a été un
petit peu on va dire au niveau des des
banlieux qui qui a été un peu perdu mais
pour plein de raisons en fait c'est pas
forcément en lien aux interventions des
forces de l'ordre mais on arrive plus à
discuter donc c'est difficile les jeunes
la mentalité des jeunes ont changé donc
c'est pas forcément évident je pense
qu'avant en fait il y avait tout un tas
de par exemple si on peut parler au
niveau sociale il y avait des éducateurs
qui faisaient aussi le lien entre la
police et la population dans dans les
cités nous aussi on avait des services
spécifique d'ilotage qui all au contact
et petit à petit on a plus ces services
petit à petit peut-être qu'au niveau
social il y a eu moins de moins
d'éducateurs ce qui a fait que en fait
l'écart le fossé s'est creusé petit à
petit entre la population une partie de
la population et et les
policiers comment installer un dialogue
durable et constructif entre la police
et les habitants des
cités avau envelin Jaffar Grein et
Abdallah Slimani travaill sur cette
question depuis des années ils avaient
lancé en 2019 un projet baptisé poli
cité qui proposait des moments de
rencontre moi je me souviens de la
première rencontre que qu' avait eu
cétait c'était magique tu vois tu voyais
des jeunes avec des policiers tout le
monde autour autour de la table et puis
des gens qui disaient bah ouais on
voyait pas le truc comme ça on voyait
pas votre métier comme ça au début on a
eu des accès qui nous ont été facilités
par la préfecture et cetera pour aller
discuter avec les commissariats pour
aller discuter avec les collèges où là
on on avait une marche de manœuvre pour
vraiment mettre en place des actions et
puis après du jour au lendemain en fait
ça a été beaucoup plus difficile la
fonction public c'est comme ça il peut
on peut avoir une préfette ou un préfet
avec qui on peut très bien discuter
pendant 2 3 ans et après on aura un
nouveau préfet qui lui est moins sur
cette ligne là de dialogue entre les
forces de l'ordre et les jeunes ou même
les habitant plus largement pour penser
la relation avec la police une autre
piste est évoquée une convention
citoyenne sur la sécurité sur le modèle
de celle déjà lancée par l'Élysée sur
l'environnement et la fin de vie ouvrir
un débat national sur la sécurité pour
dire il y a un problème et dedans il y a
la formation les pratiques
policières les moyens policiers la place
justement des habitants dans cette
construction des politiques la place des
syndicats
aussi Vau envelin est depuis des années
un laboratoire des réflexion politique
sur les quartiers
populaires c'est en réaction aux émeutes
du M du taureau de
1990 que la France s'était doté d'un
ministère de la
Ville la socialiste Hélène jaoffroy y a
occupé le poste de secrétaire d'État
sous le mandat de François Hollande elle
est aujourd'hui maire de vaau envelin et
fait une proposition la création d'un
parquet
anti-émeute de même qu'on a des des
parquets spécialisés sur les questions
financières ou les questions liées aux
attentats pour recréer un lien de
confiance aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se
passe lorsque vous interrogez les plus
jeunes ils disent de toute façon la
police quoi qu'elle fasse elle a une
forme d'impunité en tout cas elle peut
faire faire ce qu'elle veut et on saura
jamais la vérité et de l'autre côté des
policiers qui disent on est en première
ligne on défend quand il y a des émeutes
on est parfois même en danger il y a pas
de reconnaissance de la Nation et au
milieu une
igpn qui ne peut pas remplir tous les
rôles puisque c'est le contrôle de la
police il faut trouver la tierce
personne qui sort de C ce regard entre
les jeunes et la police c'est l'autorité
judiciaire qui peut avoir ce
[Musique]
regard augmenter les effectifs de police
créer un nouveau cadre juridique
favoriser les rencontres entre policiers
et population à montargie et vaau
envelin des idées et des propositions
sont sur la table l'enjeu empêcher que
demain une nouvelle étincelle ne
provoque encore un embrasement
général